and why do those truck why do those
shippers want to
switch off diesel is it because of they
have goals in terms of
greenhouse gases or is it they see this
as the future and they want to invest in
it or is it cost
no real quick i want to correct
something they're not letter intense
they're actually contracts we've got
scattered yeah billions and billions of
dollars with the contracts
so um i want to be clear about that
because a lot of people thought that
it's just like a non-committal thing
it's not these are like
signed on the dotted line billions and
billions and billions and billions of
dollars in orders
now we have to deliver and they can get
out if we don't deliver but that's how
it is with any contract you do in life
like
you know if they even order a peterbilt
they can still back out if peterbilt
doesn't give them a truck
and those folks who are buying those
would not go through the time to sign
them
uh if they did not have the intent
exactly i mean these are big companies
they they want to be
they're they're actually planning right
now like we have calls with
anheuser-busch on a monthly basis where
we're talking about okay when's the
delivery what days are these trucks
coming in when's the hydrogen station
going and when's the permit going in
because they actually have to phase out
their diesels this is like real serious
stuff
it's not a joke and if you miss it it's
it's tens or hundreds of millions
oh they have to phase it out for
environmental reasons that vary by
state in the united states correct yeah
those well this because of these cycles
so they have a
they have like a three-year lease cycle
on a truck or whatever and they have to
phase out those diesels when ours come
in so if they miss that
that window has to be within like one or
two months of each other and if you're
off you're gonna get sued
it's a it's a very complex thing it's
not simple just to go
switch out you know switch out from one
truck
to a whole brand new one it's a
complicated mess